give a really short presentation because
a lot of my work is not with me right
now and I just got stuck and I flew in
today so uh oh yeah sure I'll use this
so I'll keep the presentation very short
probably 10 or 15 minutes not more of
time I know the talk says about discrete
choice models but I don't have the
results with me right now I just gone
stuck in like I had to cut short my
presentation so but nonetheless the work
that i did is a lot of a kind of an
interest because there are very few
tools in this domain and i was able to
integrate python and bio team together
like in a and make a nice i buy thin
workflow so I'll explain as it goes
along on github it's a Russian pundit I
guess my internet is not up right now
LLL update it later it's not up on
github right now this town so my name is
dashing barnett i am a transportation
engineering student and university of
maryland i also am a research assistant
with national center for smart growth
and even university of maryland we do a
lot of planning work for them so it
typically involves lot of policymaking
how are your net transportation networks
gonna change and how is the traffic
going to involved over a period of next
30 years or 40 years and it gets
interesting because we want to
understand how people behave how people
make choices and you know with the pace
at which technology is changing in
transportation right now it's really an
interesting domain to be working in a
apart from that I am also my advisor dr.
changes we do we have a research group
that basically it just works on trying
to understand how people make decisions
and what is the impact
over your car car market is going to
evolve or the next ten years given that
you have electric vehicles penetrating
in etc so my twitter handle is there so
needless to say we are changing the
waving commute rapidly in this thinking
it is happening probably in the early
nineteen hundreds in the first half of
this century like you had the American
dream when you got a car you could go
anywhere you had massive investments in
infrastructure but now you know people
are getting smarter we are moving
towards a more healthier commute i would
say in a certain way so the concept is
like you are either traveling actively
we're in your biking or you're probably
hoverboarding or just having fun or
you're doing some kind of a passive
commute so like for example automated
vehicles when you're just listening to
music for reading PDF documents where
you are traveling this is the future
that we are probably going in and that's
why it's a very different form of
transportation because you want to
understand how it's going to affect
people apart from that you have a car
pooling now which is a big thing now and
you also have car share like Zipcar and
rental cars going up really really
taking it up the notch so you have those
things coming in and that's why you're
going to have a very different landscape
of transportation in the next decade or
two we are going to need to invest more
in infrastructure for all of these
systems and we need to make these
systems matter and that is exactly why
these problems are interesting and carry
a lot of way so one of the simplest
problems that you can handle with is
like you know there's a lot of data
available on bike share data sets so
there's a capital bikeshare there's a
new york bike-share there's data from
Chicago Boston Portland also has a very
good data set so a lot of these bike
shares they actually have their data
open so you can go and work on them and
they are really interesting sets because
you can actually understand how people
make decisions and how it affects so
something that I did was I downloaded
this is excellent utility by Tylan
Bartlett to kind of download the capital
bikeshare data and like just join them
together and do some basic manipulations
typically it's an OD pair data set so
you have trip origin destinations and
like you kind of aggregate that into and
you have like so typically in
transportation we aggregate time into
time of days because that's more or less
how we are interested in working so I
discretized I'm into like five time
periods also you remove the outliers so
there's this utility which is really
nice I don't have the output for this
right now because I have it on my server
and I can't connect to it and it is take
me time the second data said that i am
using his openstreetmap so from
openstreetmap you have this X api api
which kind of it's a read-only
openstreetmap API which allows you to
download like massive tara's like you
can either download like the entire dump
or you can download I am just interested
in restaurants for DC area so you just
give it a bounding box and you just pass
it and cranny it's something like ru
equal to pass off and it will just give
you all the bus stops in the bounded
region and its really interesting and
nice so I'm using that and a lot of this
can be reused so I hope people use it
something that we love to work with is a
bit more of a control Tina said so
there's this database called a smart
location database which kind of gives me
a statistics on census tract level I
guess so what I do is basically for
every station I am finding out in which
census tract it belongs and then like I
averaged out the nearby census tracts to
basically get these properties so i'm
using population densities employment
job densities a commute distance so for
example like how many jobs are available
within 45 minutes of commute distance
and percentage of households having 0 1
or 2 plus cars this is also very
important given the context that you are
trying to estimate how many people are
biking so that is the database that I'm
using over there so after this you
basically and find to compute the
distance matrix for facial which
basically gives me a the distance
between each station and for each
capital bikeshare station after that
there's this code where and I am doing
some more manipulation to compute the
distance between each attribute in my
database like for example open geo
OpenStreetMap data will give me
different attributes and like I try to
compute distance from of each attribute
from that predictable bike-share station
and then I basically compute a matrix
that will that is basically
I don't want to run this right now it'd
take time
so eventually I will get a matrix that
just goes by facility time so i am
dividing the entire OpenStreetMap data
into facility types i am dividing it
into leisure up i should have that
written somewhere oh yeah shops
buildings education leisure and railway
and pass so basically it's just a factor
that says station let's say methylene
station is really close to a lot of
shops and shopping areas or leisure
areas but it's really not close to any
education centers well compared to
college park so the score for that will
be much lower so i basically compute the
distance to distance between let's say
each each education institution to all
the bike-share stations and then if it's
not in the walkable distance i just top
it off otherwise i just normalize it
like normalize it and distribute its
weight so if you are 10 kilometers away
sorry if you are like 100 meters away
you get ten percent of the traffic as
compared to a station that is 900 meters
of sorry the other way around if you're
900 meters away you get ten percent of
the traffic and if you're 100 meters
away you get ninety percent of the
traffic so that's how you split I try to
split the weight age and this also goes
into the factor so basically at the end
of this what you do get is a matrix that
goes like for each station you get
different weights for each of those
openstreetmap attributes so station pike
share station a has an attribute of
let's say point 35 for leisure and point
two five of Education so after this I
basically run a linear regression model
and I have results for that right now
with me so there are problems with
regression because because the
significance is not that good and this
is not exactly why you'll use linear
regression thing man a lot of our
attributes are actually choices that
people make they are not continuous
choices so you cannot directly use and
understand or imply the effects of that
but nonetheless I just put in a simple
linear regression model to estimate and
divine this is the weekdays trip of
production for a station and here are
the different coefficient factors for
each of these variables so if you see a
towards the evening the residential
density is basically has a significant
coefficient and towards the morning if
you see the paths and education have a
significantly higher coefficient and a
lot of these significant sins of these
variables or coefficients is not that
high but you can still see an internal
observer friend and then make up and you
know just remove certain variables that
are not significant and come up with a
good linear predictor model that will
just say what the demand is similarly if
you see weekends this was particularly
interesting there is a the effect of in
the afternoon on weekends you see lesion
has a negative coefficient to an extent
which was very weird but in the butt but
commute is also again very high and then
that's a that's a very different kind of
you know behavior that you see out of
this data set because you assume that in
DC people kind of tend to travel you
know more for leisure purposes then for
business purposes but there is kind of a
little deviation from what I observed oh
yeah there's that
a survey paper by Capital Bikeshare in
which they did some survey and they
found out a positive correlation between
a number of pubs in in the nearby
vicinity to the traffic that you have
and which makes sense particularly on
weekends but in general like if you see
morning and other trends it does not
have that much effect similarly on being
days the attraction of the of a
particular station is affected by the
number of jobs and number of employment
residences in that region and of course
there is like a significant factor of
car ownership also so as you can see
this that people are taking cars and
like you know trying to catch bike to
work and that is being observed some of
these variables are significant soil
I'll be attaching the results also in
the workbook so you can see that
statistical results for that so in
general after this there is this thurs
to like go in and say okay I want to
explore regions where you are seeing
this effect where in like you know if
you have people who own toward more
cause they are still biking or like or
people who don't have cars are biking
and what are those stations and how do I
understand the spatial effects so that
is exactly why I wanted to do this but I
don't have the results now right now so
what I was able to do was to try and fit
in a multinomial logit model using these
parameters and one of the problems with
a lot of this effort is that that there
are basically two major tools that you
can use one is pie orgy and the other is
a em logit in our which I don't use and
there's a starter starter package which
is paid so we can't afford that so by
regime is de facto the standard that
everybody uses but by
team is a little quirky like you need
the Linux installation which most of the
transportation engineers don't have or
you need a standalone console and you
need to write down cryptic logit files
and do data manipulation and then send
it those files so what I was able to do
was to use a our Python I by the
notebook framework and then use just one
more library patsy to kind of configure
the model and configure the data set and
then I was able to write down the
matrices out into a CSV file and then
just call a Python Biogen from command
line in ipython itself so eventually you
don't ever have to go out of ipython
console you just there I mean it's not
the best situation but I Python Biogen
basically runs in a different it's
basically just a boat and just called c
function like that is the easiest way to
get it done so i hope a lot of people
are going to use that so i will be
updating it on my github account i will
be posting i will be sharing that as
well and the results are not that good
for that but i made an effort in that
direction trying to integrate by og man
python together so yeah that was so yeah
that's it thank you and questions yes
sorry so I have two questions on the one
hand just with my experience in DC with
Capital Bikeshare I feel like there's a
lot of people taking one-way trips I was
going to look into that at all parents
on the other and one second question was
and you did some analysis in terms of
bugs and stuff like that if you look at
me checking data from people checking
into different establishments exactly
but I guess foursquare isn't really use
that much yeah I basically the initial
Indian for this was actually from one of
my goals products are to find fill the
gravity model of so you can find make
you know estimating traffic than you
think is linear regression model this
was last semester I just wanted to go in
and make a gravity model and just say
okay we want to put out put in new
stations where should we put them in
what is the pattern that we are going to
see but i am not very happy with these
linear models with regards to check in
data yes it can be helpful but that is
more enhancement to be data so you
actually know where they are going but
that is a bit more advanced than this a
lot of work is actually done in some
there are these models called as
activity-based more instant a lot of
transportation people might know they
basically use a national household
travel survey data and the basically
long story short it just says on an
average people go to work in the morning
with a probability of point eight five
and they use that so many done kind of
simulate ornate you know populated or
micro sim daily trips and you basically
use census data and the nhtsa done
basically generate I i call it SimCity
on a massive scale so you just a brief
and populate micro simulations on that
and then
understand how people behave that is a
big research area that that people are
working on and ready yeah so so taking
later can we use there but like
rudimentary demand estimation models it
is not very useful I guess I forgot your
second question so my second question
was about one-way trips and if you what
kind of insights you've done without
that and Palace and also this palace
capital where the bike share system
managed one-way trips one you know what
station is empty yeah the motor station
right before do they take the bikes over
a word ah so I even particularly look
into that problem rebalancing is like a
big research area it goes more on the
operations side but bike-share
rebalancing is definitely a big problem
and there are a couple of papers I can
probably share up to peoples and
researchers from my university I so
everyone know so yep I haven't done
anything on it any questions all right
thank you I apologize for not giving out
discrete choice models today but like I
did make an effort and I'll most post it
together so you can see how by regime
integrates nicely with I bike so yeah
thank you